11. Dumbledore's memory of Voldemort's
interview the last of Dumbledore's
memories for us to cover today it's
another memory of an interview that
Dumbledore conducted for a position at
Hogwarts this time however the interview
was with a wizard who did not get the
job Voldemort the scene shows a version
of an older Tom Riddle whose appearance
has already begun to resemble that of
Voldemort in the memory he has
supposedly come to apply for the open
position Professor for defense against
the dark arts of course what becomes
clear is that he never intended to get
the role rather he uses the opportunity
to curse the position in perpetuity
which is the reason no Dana Professor
ever lasted more than a year after that
he then went on to hide one of his
horcruxes ravenclaws died him in the
Castle's room of requirements